LARS BAK: Hello.
Welcome, everybody.
Oh.
They fixed the sound.
Great.
So welcome to the Dart,
a modern web language
presentation.
This is the first ever
presentation about
Dart at Google IO.
And I'm here.
I'm Lars Bak with Kaspar Lund,
coming all the way from
Denmark to present Dart.
I can just say right away, we
will not be doing any base
jumping nor stage diving.
This will be fairly boring
in that respect.
What I can tell you about is
about this new programming
language we have been working
on for a year.
And this presentation will
include a few things.
We'll talk about the
motivation for it.
And part of the motivation
is our work on V8.
Kasper and I have been working
on V8 for many years, I guess.
Four or so?
KASPER LUND: Four years, yeah.
LARS BAK: Four years.
And some of the experience
with JavaScript
has led us to Dart.
We'll be talking about
the basic language.
We'll be talking about some of
the components we have in the
Dart project.
And then we'll talk about the
bright future we hopefully
have with Dart.
So let's get started.
We have a lot of interesting
stuff to talk about.
So our background is in
implementing virtual machines.
And as you probably can see,
I'm the oldest one.
He's the younger version.
I've been doing VMs for 26
years, and Kasper's been doing
it for the last 12.
We've worked together
on many projects.
We've been doing Java,
virtual machines.
Also JavaScript engines,
like V8.
And that's been pretty cool.
So this is our first project
ever where we've been
designing a programming
language.
KASPER LUND: Before I joined
Lars on this mission to try to
improve the performance of
virtual machines for various
languages--
Lars was working on more exotic
languages, too, like
the Beta programming language,
sort of a Scandinavian
object-oriented language.
So there's a lot of experience
on the stage here.
Nearly 40 years combined.
So we certainly know a thing or
two about virtual machines,
so hopefully we can convince
you that we know a thing or
two about languages as well.
LARS BAK: So first of all, there
will be a little bit of
a salute to the web.
We think the web is fantastic.
The web is everywhere today.
You have it on your
mobile phone, your
pads and your desktop.
So when you do an application
it can actually cover most
devices today.
It's also very easy to
use as a developer.
You can just pop into your
favorite text editor, type in
a few lines, and then you can
start it up in your browser.
There's no tool chain
involved in getting
the program up running.
And one thing I really like
about the web, there's no
required installation
of the app.
Whenever you start Gmail, you
get the newest version.
So you are not bothered
by these updates.
I assume you all have
mobile phones?
Have you tried to get bothered
by an update notification?
I guess.
For me, at least, that's one
of the benefits of the web.
That you don't have to install
an application.
Furthermore it's also a very
incremental experience, to
develop for the web.
You can change one line in the
program and use a refresh.
So within a second, you can
have your application up
running again.
And that's very appealing
when you do prototype
develop and so on.
And one thing that's even
better, the browser industry
is right now fairly
competitive.
All the browser vendors, they're
competing on speed and
functionality.
And most implementations are
open source, so it's a
friendly competition.
Here's my best attempt
to make a wheel.
It turned out to
be three-sided.
But I'm trying to explain
the ecosystem of browser
development.
When you add more performance
into a browser, you will sort
of enable application developers
to innovate.
They can add more functionality
on the client
side, and that again will
require new browser features.
And so on and so forth.
And this is great, because
whenever you take a turn with
this wheel, the browser will be
a better place to develop
applications and also
use applications.
Here's a JavaScript performance
improvement chart.
It'll show you the speedup
of JavaScript
over the last 12 years.
And as you can see, there
was a dry spell
of a number of years.
And then we introduced in
2008, Chrome, the beta
version, where V8 was
part of that.
And you can see, since 2008 the
performance of JavaScript
has just improved
tremendously.
In fact, JavaScript is now 100
times faster on the same
hardware, compared to a browser
five years ago.
That's pretty amazing,
isn't it?
KASPER LUND: That's
a lot, yeah.
LARS BAK: Even on mobile
devices, like an Android
device, you can see that the
performance of JavaScript is
comparable to a desktop
machine, when we
introduced V8 in 2008.
So this is pretty amazing.
And it really allows you guys to
do better apps on the web.
KASPER LUND: We've already seen
a few things that have
come along that take advantage
of this new power.
So the point with the previous
slide, where performance
improvements of the core
platform really help you
innovate, can be seen in one
of the latest versions of
Google Maps for instance,
where you can enable
client-side rendering of
things-- things that you had
to do on the server side before,
it's now possible to
do on the client instead.
Which is pretty cool.
So we certainly see that this
is already now helping a lot
on what you can do and
achieve with the web.
LARS BAK: So during this period
the web applications
have become more and
more complex.
And have posed some challenges
for the web.
What we really want, we want
to have better programmer
productivity.
And we also want application
scalability, so that as you
get bigger and bigger
applications the browser can
cope with it as you
execute it.
And then of course you need
raw execution speed.
We've fixed some of that with
V8, but we are not hitting the
glass ceiling yet.
One thing that's a problem
today, at least from my point
of view, is that startup
performance is not where we
want it to be.
When you start up a big web
app, it's fairly slow.
For instance, if you take Gmail,
you have to read in a
lot of source code before you
can start the application.
And that sort of delays
the startup with
half to a full second.
So the final item on this slide
here is that if we don't
innovate, the web will lose out
to mobile apps, where they
can install more native
types of applications.
Fortunately, we have
a solution for you.
We have the Dart platform.
And this is a suite of
technologies that will
hopefully solve so some
of these issues with
the existing platform.
Our high-level goals
are fairly simple.
We want to make a simple,
productive programming
alignment and programming
language that supports for
programming in the large.
And we also want to have
predictable high performance.
And that means that when you
write your code, you can
expect some sort
of performance.
Right now it's complicated
with JavaScript.
It often depends on what the
browser optimized, how good
performance you get out of it.
We want to have ultra-fast
startup.
Things that take more than
100 milliseconds are just
unacceptable.
And then of course, we are
not out to break the web.
We really want to have
compatibility
with all modern browsers.
And we'll show you how we've
done that in Dart, by
providing a translator from
Dart to JavaScript.
So.
KASPER LUND: Let's talk
about JavaScript.
LARS BAK: Let's do that.
KASPER LUND: So, I don't know
how many people in here are
familiar with JavaScript.
There are some that know it.
OK.
That's good.
How many people here
actually work with
JavaScript every day?
Good crowd.
I like that.
So hopefully you're aware of
some fundamental issues with
JavaScript.
I'm going to run through a few
of them, just to give you a
feel for the kind of issues
we're trying to tackle.
So one big issue we see with
JavaScript is it's very hard
to reason about where the
problem is actually defined.
There is almost no declarative
syntax, and it's very hard, if
not impossible sometimes, to
find dependencies between
different components in a
language like JavaScript.
It's not uncommon and not
unheard of that in JavaScript
you do monkey patching of core
functionality to add your
message to the object
[? or ?] prototype.
And that makes it even harder to
reason about what's defined
where, and who uses what.
And understanding the program
structure is really, really
important if you want to be
efficient as a programmer.
You need to be able to do code
maintenance and refactoring,
and that really requires you to
have a full and very good
understanding of the
program structure.
You also need that understanding
of the program
structure if you want to write
a good tool that can analyze
your code, and work with it, and
allow you to debug it and
maybe navigate the code
in a clever way.
So it's actually really
hard in JavaScript.
Let me give you a
small example of
what I mean with that.
So here's a very, very simple
JavaScript function, meant as
a constructor for points.
So the fields of this point
class, that I'm trying to
simulate in JavaScript, are
not actually declared
anywhere, except that they are
implicitly defined by the
statements that I put in the
constructor that assign x and
y to this.x and this.y.
This seems simple enough,
and pretty nice.
And you could probably write a
tool that works with this kind
of information.
But in reality it's often more
complicated than this.
So in JavaScript we often see
code like this, for instance,
where you really want to make
these properties non-writable,
like read-only.
And suddenly you have to go
through actual control flow in
your constructors, to figure
out what kind of fields you
end up having on all
your points.
Of course, this is a trivial
example, so a very good tool
could probably analyze this
code and understand what
you're doing.
But for real applications,
this really quickly gets
really, really hard.
If you look at the tools out
there today for working with
JavaScript code, it is pretty
clear that it's not an easy
problem to solve.
I mean, there are good
tools coming
out, and it's improving.
But it's really hard.
Another very fundamental issue
with JavaScript is this keep
on trucking mentality.
So JavaScript has this idea
that it's a good thing to
tolerate mistakes in the
program, and it's OK to
operate on unexpected types, and
it's OK if that actually
just leads to unusable or
unexpected results.
So at the point in your code
where you introduce an error,
you're very unlikely
to get that error.
And it's much more likely that
the value you get out of that
mistake you put in will just
flow through your program and
end up causing a problem
later on.
That just makes it very, very
hard to find your problem.
Almost anything goes.
For the program productivity,
it's much better to throw
errors more eagerly.
So it makes it much easier to
locate the source of an error,
and it gives you many of the
errors when you're testing
your code, not at run time
at the end user's side.
So it gives you more
confidence in the
deployed apps, too.
It's really a good thing
for writing large scale
applications and being able to
trust that they actually work
as intended.
Let me give you a few
examples of that.
So in JavaScript,
constructors for
objects are just functions.
That seems pretty
nice and simple.
I can use the function
as a constructor.
It just sort of works.
So if we build on the point
example from before, we can
clearly allocate a point by
using that as a constructor.
But what happens if we actually
forget to write new
in front of that constructor
application?
Well, it turns out it works.
It doesn't give you an error.
It's fine.
It does give you the point
undefined back., and
additionally it gives you two
extra global variables, x and
y, that have the
value 2 and 3.
So you don't get a point, but
you get extra state and the
global object.
That seems unintended, kind of
weird, and just is a real
source of errors.
We see this every day.
During the development of V8
we've been through quite a lot
of JavaScript code written by
many, many people, and these
sort of subtle bugs
always pop up.
LARS BAK: And one more thing.
The interesting part is that
undefined [? integers, ?]
you can see here, you
can't even rely on.
Because it's mutable.
You can change that property.
So most people that would write
correct code, in this
case, will instead of undefined
use [? write ?]
zero.
That makes sense
to you, right?
KASPER LUND: Yeah, it does.
I don't know how many
people that make
sense to, but anyway.
Let's take another example.
This is probably the most common
source of issues in
JavaScript.
If you have a typo in your
code, that gives you real
problems and it's
hard to find.
So I put some code up here
that uses an XML
HTTP request object.
And the intent is, of course,
to install a callback that
will get invoked whenever the
ready state changes, and if we
reach the done state,
which is state 4,
will log in to console.
Very simple.
Unfortunately this
does not work.
The console will never have
anything here, even if the
ready state does change to 4.
Because ready state is spelled
with a capital S. So
JavaScript allows this,
and it's just fine.
It just gives you undefined
every single time you try to
read the ready state with a
lowercase S. And undefined is
not equal to 4.
Maybe it should be,
I don't know.
Anyway, it's this kind of thing
that makes you less
productive as a programmer.
And it kind of sucks.
If we're sort of continuing on
that trend, we can also take a
look at implicit conversions.
There have been some pretty
funny videos circulating the
web with more examples like
this, but this is a very
simple one.
So here we have a string.
Strings in JavaScript
are values.
They're immutable, you
cannot change them.
If you try, do like string
dot hash equals
something, it's accepted.
What actually happens here is
that you actually implicitly
convert string to a string
object that wraps that string.
And you can access properties
on that, you can even set
properties on that.
The only problem is you actually
throw that temporary
object away just after having
done it, so it has no effect.
So when you try to assert that
string dot hash is something
reasonable afterwards,
it's undefined.
And again, I probably should
have put void 0 here.
Because you get a different
object wrapped around the
string value to grab
hold of the hash.
This is surprising
to many people.
And often you use this kind of
trick to try to add some
caching to your code.
And it seems to work just fine,
except that you never
get any caching out of it.
It's a performance problem, and
it's just annoying to have
to deal with.
I think I can top
the last slide.
How about this one?
I don't know if anyone here can
tell me why 2.0 should be
equal to the string two, that
is equal to a Boolean object
that wraps the true value,
that is equal
to the string one.
But it is.
There are so many implicit
conversions going on here that
it makes my head explode.
And having to implement this
in V8, it was a lot of fun.
But sometimes you have to doubt
whether or not the value
you get out of these implicit
conversions
is worth the trouble.
LARS BAK: Actually if you take
the [INAUDIBLE] script
standard and go through
specification, you'll figure
out that you need at least six
implicit conversions of
objects before you can evaluate
this expression.
KASPER LUND: Yeah, and they go
in different directions.
Like sometimes you convert to
numbers implicitly, sometimes
to strings, sometimes from
objects to primitive values.
It's pretty messy.
Another big issue that we see,
and this is of course also
coming from the low level, from
the VM side up, is that
JavaScript has really
unpredictable performance.
There's sort of an advice
floating around that you
should just try to use the
efficient subset of
JavaScript.
Because VMs over the last few
years have been optimized for
certain patterns.
And if you want to benefit
from the performance
improvements, and you probably
do want to do that, you have
to hit that sweet spot, and have
all your code fit in that
efficient subset.
The problem is that it's
actually kind of hard to find
that subset.
Nobody can tell you what
that subset is.
It depends on the browser,
it depends on the
version of the browser.
And it's not just about using
the right syntactic
constructs.
It can be about not fetching
local variables from the
context chain.
It can be about many
different things.
If you see a site like
jsperf.com, where people try
to upload these mini-snippets
of code to figure out what
works well in certain browsers,
this is an act of
desperation.
People are trying to figure
out what works well.
They just don't know.
So the only way to write a
really high-performance
JavaScript application is
to profile all the time.
That takes time, again limiting
your productivity.
So you can do amazing things
with JavaScript.
It's just kind of tricky
and time consuming.
And JavaScript performance
is pretty unpredictable.
Sometimes it's really great, and
sometimes you get like a
factor of 20 slower code, just
by using some slightly less
common version of something.
That's not a good place to be.
LARS BAK: All right.
So this is the summary for
the JavaScript portion.
And as Kasper stated, programs
are hard to understand when
you look at the source code.
And it's also hard to reason
about if you're a tool.
One thing that's really bad in
JavaScript is you can monkey
patch the basic objects.
That means that if you have two
different components that
rely on the same library,
you get into problems.
Because if one component patches
the library in a way
the other component cannot
handle, then
your program breaks.
So compatibility is
out the window.
Keep on trucking mentality is
just surprising to most.
And we have gotten programs
in to analyze
where this is an error.
So programmers actually sent
their programs out, in
production, with these keep on
trucking errors in them.
And then of course there's
unpredictability about the code.
You should try to take your
favorite fast-running
JavaScript code and put delete
property in a crucial place,
and then the performance
[? quota ?]
will go down the toilet.
So this was the motivational
part.
And hopefully you can see
innovation is needed, if you
want to move the platform
forward so it's more
productive for programmers.
So let's talk about that.
And you'll get that
in one slide.
It's here.
KASPER LUND: Here it is.
LARS BAK: So since we're VM
developers, we don't really
know how to design languages.
So we thought a good idea would
be to take different
languages, and take the best
aspects of them, and
put them into one.
So Dart is basically sort of a
combination of the syntax from
JavaScript, the [? optional ?]
types in Strongtalk, the
object model in Smalltalk, some
concepts from C#, and
then an isolate model that's
inspired by Erlang.
So that is very simple.
And to specify what it is,
is an unsurprising simple
[INAUDIBLE]
language.
With simple inheritance-- we
have classes, and we have
interfaces, and we have
a familiar syntax.
So if you know how to program in
C# or Java or JavaScript, I
would expect that you can get
productive within a few hours.
KASPER LUND: One thing that's
worth mentioning here is that
at some point we found that
if you want to develop a
language, design it to make it
appealing to people, it has to
have curly braces.
It is not possible to come up
with a mainstream programming
language that gets any
kind of acceptance
without curly braces.
So we have tons of
curly braces.
You're welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
LARS BAK: It's sad, but true.
So let me just go on.
So here is the point
example in Dart.
This is the first Dart
example of this talk.
And there's a class
named point.
It has two fields, x and y.
And there's a constructor.
And parameters for the
constructor are this.x and
this.y means when you call the
constructor it will assign the
parameters to the two fields.
So there's no body of the
constructor in this case.
It also has an operator plus
that takes us another point,
and then it returns a new point
that's actually the
addition of the two points, the
receiver and the parameter.
Here you can see the shorthand
notation for a function, where
you see the arrow.
Syntax just means that there's
one expression to the right,
and the function will return the
result of that expression.
There's also a to string method,
and it returns a
string so you can see what
coordinates the point has.
Here we're using string
interpolation, it's fairly
obvious what's going on.
And then we have a top level
main that creates a new point.
And then it has an expression
where we add one point to
another point, which
is new point 4, 5.
One thing I should point out,
you cannot call the
constructor without new.
That's a good thing.
KASPER LUND: Hopefully this
syntax does not look
too scary to people.
I mean, the feedback we've
gotten so far is that this
kind of code is actually fairly
easy for people to just
read on the slide
and understand.
That's exactly what
we're going for.
LARS BAK: When we designed the
language, we looked at various
attempts to make scalable
programs.
And there needs to be a way
where the programmer can
specify the intent
of a library.
And one way of doing that
is by specifying type
annotations.
And we have that in Dart.
They're optional, though.
So you can write without
types if you want to.
And as your program matures and
you get more structure on
it, you can add the types
any time you want.
But they act as checkable
documentation for the code and
the interfaces.
So you can decide only to put in
types in the interface, but
you can also decide to really
put in static types everywhere
in your program.
And people that are familiar
with the Java or C#, they have
a tendency to do that.
We also have generics.
And that makes really useful, so
you can specify you have a
list of apples or a
set of oranges.
States intent.
The type system is a little
bit special in that it is
considered unsound, because we
allow downcasts when steadily
checking a Dart program.
However, these abilities
are run time.
So if you violate the assignment
rules, you'll get a
runtime error.
But it makes it very,
very flexible.
And I'll show you that on the
next slide, hopefully.
Or the next slide.
This one here is the point
example again, where we have
added the types.
So you can see that the fields
are now annotated with num,
which is a number in Dart.
And also the return type of the
operator plus will be a
point, and the parameter to
that is also a point.
So you can see, if you contrast
it to the first
example, as little changes
you have to make in
order to type it.
And this hopefully here also
is very easy to read.
KASPER LUND: We see people start
out without writing a
lot of type notations.
While they're prototyping, just
wanted to get some things
done, they will write in a style
where they have less
type notations.
And once they want to coordinate
their work with
coworkers, or maybe send it out
for a code review, they
will add more types to try to
document what they felt like
doing, an what the different
constructs were meant to do.
Usually we end up having types
in interfaces and return types
and parameters, and
less types in the
implementations of methods.
But it's a matter of taste,
and you can choose,
essentially, what you like.
LARS BAK: So to some of you
that are used to generics,
from Java or C#, this might
sound surprising.
But we have covariant
generic types.
And it basically means that if
apple is a fruit, then a list
of apples is clearly
a list of fruits.
In this example we have
the main function.
It calls a pick apples
from a tree, and it
returns a list of apples.
And then you call the print
fruits method--
hello--
and that takes a
list of fruits.
And it seems to work.
And that's how it should work.
But if you take Java or
C#, that will fail.
Because if you take these two
generic types in these
languages, they are unrelated.
And the type system cannot
cope with it.
It works like you
want it to work.
KASPER LUND: That's exactly
what I wanted to say.
This fits with your intuition
in most cases.
And of course there are some
theoretical reasons why other
languages have not
done this before.
But this actually works pretty
well in practice.
So it does give you some
runtime checks
every now and then.
But it works really
well in practice.
And it makes the types
not get in your way
LARS BAK: All right.
So let's go for a small demo.
KASPER LUND: Let me show you
just a tiny bit of Dart code,
and how it works in practice.
And I want to try to illustrate
how these types can
be checked at runtime to give
you very recognizable and very
strong error signals, that allow
you to fix issues in
your code much more quickly.
So here's an instance of the
Dart editor running.
I'm not going to go into a lot
of detail about the editor.
You should come to the next talk
at 2:45 in Room Three.
You'll get much more insights
into what the editor can do
and how it works.
This will just be
a small teaser.
So here I have a
sunflower demo.
I can show you that running in
our custom build of Chrome,
that has the Dart VM enabled.
And it's a fairly simple,
small thing.
It just allows me to have a
slider and adjust the size of
this sunflower thing.
If I go back to the editor and
I deliberately introduce a
small issue in the code--
let me scroll down here,
find the main thing.
Something like messing up and
providing a rubbish argument
to draw frame.
Instead of providing the
context, I'll give it the
canvas instead.
I'll say that.
And because the VM is enabled
in this Dart [INAUDIBLE], I
can just go and refresh the
browser, and it gets the
latest source code.
No compilation necessary.
What actually happens is I go
back into the editor, because
this actually gives
me an exception.
Because I'm supposed to be
passing a canvas rendering
context 2D.
That's a nice, short name.
It wants the context, and I'm
giving it a canvas instead.
So I get a very recognizable
error, right here when I have
the mistake.
It doesn't try to keep
on trucking.
And it really helps me, as a
developer, to figure out what
I messed up.
So this was a very small teaser,
just to show you that
the checking of these types at
runtime can really help you
just find those issues
really quickly.
LARS BAK: And this is a good
example, where there's a
mixture between untyped
code and typed code.
And even though you have a
mixture, the typing in the
type part will help you validate
that you used the
code the right way.
KASPER LUND: So the canvas
that I provided as the
argument was untyped.
That's OK to pass to something
that expects a type, but we
will check it.
Let's go back to the
presentation, here.
LARS BAK: All right.
Since this is a full language,
we decided to select a small
portfolio of cool language
features I hope you like.
So let's go through
them quickly.
So we have name constructors.
And it means that you can have
more than one constructor in
the same class.
In this case here we
have added a name
constructor to point.
It's called polar.
So if you have polar
coordinates, you can pass that
in and also create a point.
The main reason for doing that
is we don't have type
overloading in Dart.
And this will give you
flexibility compared to other
languages, where you often
have to do several steady
factory methods to get
to the same result.
So, cool feature.
Next.
We have interfaces.
But what we have also added
something called default
implementations to interfaces.
And it's mainly designed so that
novice users do not have
to know all the implementation
types in the system.
So all they have to know is
the simple interfaces.
And you can say new to a list,
which is an interface, and the
only thing that will happened
is it will just delegate the
constructor call to the default
implementation.
And in this case it's the
list [? factoring. ?]
So we created two lists
for you here.
In main, the first one,
is just a list
without a generic parameter.
And in that list you can add
any update you have.
The second one is a
list of points.
You can pass the optional
parameter linked to it.
So we'll get a list of 12
elements, and you can only add
points to it.
KASPER LUND: So if you look at
the list constructor up in the
interface, that square bracket
notation means that that
parameter is optional.
It can be provided by
the caller, and
it can not be provided.
The default implementation gets
to decide what to do it
it's not provided, and in this
case it just initializes the
list with zero elements and
you get to add your stuff
afterwards.
But it's a nice thing that you
can specify in the interface,
that the intent is that you can
provide this if you want
to, or you may not want to do
that and you get the default
behavior instead.
So that's another language
feature on the same slide.
Like two in one.
LARS BAK: Next one is
cascaded calls.
How many of you have
used Smalltalk?
KASPER LUND: Wow.
LARS BAK: Out of the five,
how many like cascaded
[? sends? ?]
Nobody?
Anyways, we have added
cascaded [? sends. ?]
I'm a true believer in them.
So it basically means we have a
construct that allows you to
do multiple calls on
the same object.
Here's an example where you
want to draw a circle.
You get the canvas, the
x- and y-coordinates,
and the size in.
And you first compute the
context from the canvas, and
then you want to do a
number of calls on
that object, the context.
And this is how it's
done in Dart.
You use the dot dot notation,
and it means that you first
call beginPath on the context,
then arc, then fill, then
closePath, and then stroke.
It's just a simple way to avoid
introducing yet another
local variable.
KASPER LUND: It also gives us
great typing information.
So if you have a canvas out of
context and that is typed in
the definition of the canvas,
the system will know and be
able to give you code completion
suggestions when
you're doing these
cascaded things.
So it helps, at least if the
alternative was to do a bar
declaration, and have
to go through all
the things with that.
So this is shorter, and
nicer in many ways.
LARS BAK: Here's
another thing.
This illustrates how we do
proper capturing of loop
variables in Dart.
Here's a function called main.
It has a list called closures.
And we have a for loop from zero
to eight, where we add a
closure each time you
execute the loop.
And in this case here, it's just
a function that returns
the [? count of variable ?] i.
In most languages what happens
if you execute this code as
specified--
by the way, at the end here
we go through the list of
closures, and then evaluate
the closure
and print the result.
If you do that in C# or in
JavaScript, you'll get a
number of eights out, because
all the closures were referred
to the same loop variable.
In Dart it's different.
In Dart, you'll introduce a new
loop variable each time
you enter the loop.
So in Dart, you'll see the
results 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
And this is a common mistake
when you use closures for
programming.
KASPER LUND: We have a number
of examples from JavaScript,
again, where we see people
using asynchronous API.
And they have to be very careful
to capture the right
variables and the
right values.
So there's a lot of small
mistakes in that, and you see
a lot of weird things
going on with that.
So we decided to try to fix
that, and make it simpler for
programmers to reason
about this.
LARS BAK: So to us Dart is
beautiful, even though we took
most of the components
and curly
braces from other languages.
It's declarative, so we think
it's easy to read.
And it's certainly toolable.
We don't do any implicit
conversion, so the semantics
is fairly straightforward.
And the libraries are actually
read-only, so we can have
composable component and it
works, and you can rely on it.
And again, if you're used to
Java, C# or JavaScript, other
languages with curly braces,
this should be easy.
KASPER LUND: So the Dart
language is, of course, a big
part of this project.
But there is more to it.
So let me give you a brief
tour of what we're doing.
Language is only part
of the story.
If you want to have a great web
development platform, that
entire platform has to be
well-tuned for helping you
guys to deliver fantastic
apps.
So developers need a great new
language, and we've tried to
argue why Dart is that
new language.
But you also need really fast
execution, and really fast
startup applications.
And you need very good tools for
developing your apps and
for analyzing your apps.
It's also very important that
you get very good integration
with the DOM.
As developers you need
all of this.
So the Dart project is not just
about the language, it's
also about innovating on the
tool side, and it's also about
giving you access to much
better and much more
predictable performance.
LARS BAK: Because we have
decided to make Dart run on
existing platforms, we have
a little bit complicated
deployment story for Dart.
And I'll try to go
through it here.
So the green stuff at
the top is your
application, plus libraries.
And you have a few
choices here.
You can run it directly on that
Dartium build, which you
saw Kasper demo before, and
it will run right away.
But you can also process
the application
library through tools.
One tool is the Dart to JS
compiler, which will translate
Dart into one single
JavaScript file.
And then you can run it
in any modern browser.
This is the part where you
should be happy we're not
trying to break the web.
Another tool we have is we can
convert an application, plus
libraries, into a snapshot.
And a snapshot is a serialized
form of the data structure
that makes applications
start up much faster.
I'll get back to that
in two slides.
KASPER LUND: This is actually
a really important point, I
think I want to make it again.
Lars already said it.
Dart is compatible with
all modern browsers.
So this is just a small cut-out
of the Buildbot we
have running on
buildbot.dartlang.org.
And it shows us testing Dart
across Firefox, Chrome,
Safari, IE and Opera.
This is actually just an
indication that we take this
compatibility issue
very seriously.
It's very dear to our hearts
to have Dart running really
well across all modern
browsers.
All the browsers here do not
have Dart VMs built in, so
here we're using the Dart to
JavaScript translation.
And we make that work across
all these browsers.
And we continue to do that and
keep that part running.
Let me just spend a few moments
on telling you about
the translation process.
We do have a compiler that
translates Dart to JavaScript.
It's written in Dart itself.
That gives us a nice excuse
for using Dart
as a language ourselves.
And it also means that
we can compile Dart--
through Dart to JS compiler--
with itself, and get a compiler
out that actually can
compile Dart to JavaScript,
that runs
in any modern browser.
That's maybe kind of freaky,
but it works really well.
You can have a JavaScript
implementation of a Dart to
JavaScript compiler by just
compiling it with itself.
I like that stuff.
LARS BAK: Maybe it'll go
to [? reflector ?] now.
KASPER LUND: So let's get
back to something more
down-to-earth.
Here's a, I think
at this point,
very well-known example.
The point, with two fields,
x and y, and a
constructor and a to string.
And it translates to something
like this on the JavaScript.
That's the right hand side.
We create a structure, give it
an endpoint, and we fill in an
explicit superclass, object in
this case, and put in a couple
fields, x and y.
And then we have a small piece
of code that actually
translates this to JavaScript
instructor at runtime, and
puts in the getters and setters
for these fields, and
it makes it nice to work with.
But the rest of the definition
of point is
actually just the methods.
So here you see the to string
method is being translated to
a JavaScript to string method,
with a dollar zero at the end.
That just means that
that function
expects zero arguments.
It's important for us to make
sure that these functions that
you call get the expected number
of arguments, so you
don't have this classical issue
in JavaScript where you
forget to provide a parameter,
and it just kind of
works in a weird way.
The to string method on the
right is a bit more verbose
than the one on the left.
And that's because of the string
interpolation feature,
where we will make it very, very
easy to convert strings,
and bits and pieces of
expressions and code, to join
them as strings.
And you see here it's translated
into a couple of
string concatenation
operations.
So we'll do this for you, and
this code runs across all
modern browsers.
LARS BAK: We have to speed
up a little bit, I think.
Anyways.
One cool thing about Dart is
that because it is declarative
we can do something called
tree shaking.
And tree shaking is this
pre-deployment step that
allows you to reduce the
size of the executable.
And what it basically means
is that you take the main
function and you start
shaking it.
Everything that you're not using
will fall off the tree,
and when you're done you can
wrap it up, and that's your
application.
So unused classes and unused
methods will be eliminated.
And the application is just
penalized for what it's using,
compared to what's being
included in libraries.
And this is great because it
helps the download time of the
application, and also helps
the startup time.
KASPER LUND: It also means that
you can depend on a big
library, and you only pay for
the small pieces of it you
actually use.
LARS BAK: You cannot do
that in JavaScript.
Why?
Well, because there's a val.
Val is a thing that
takes a string and
converts it into code.
So you cannot analyze
it statically.
The second one is, it also has
the with statement that
introduces [? voodoo, ?]
scoping.
You basically have no chance of
figuring out what's being
accessed in the outer scope.
So that's much easier in Dart,
and that is what clear
semantics will give you.
Tree shaking is already used by
dart2js today, and clearly
reduces the size of the app,
and also improves startup.
We are in the process of also
working on a tool that takes
Dart code, tree shakes it,
and emits Dart code.
So the Dart code itself will
be easier to start up.
And that will be based on the
same infrastructure as the
Dart to JS compiler.
KASPER LUND: Shaken,
not stirred.
That's the motto.
LARS BAK: Yes, James.
Another thing that should be
really cool and is already
implemented in the Dart VM
is the Dart snapshots.
And it's a binary form of the
entire Dart application.
And our measurements so far
means that you get a 10x
speedup compared to sourcing
in the application before
starting up.
And that's fantastic, because
that means that instead of
having a one second startup,
you get down below 100
milliseconds to start
up the application.
And it's very simple.
If you do the VM the right way,
you can just load the
application into the heap, and
then you serialize the heap
into a binary format.
Very simple.
And it's really, really
efficient when
you start up again.
What benefits you is you don't
have to do scanning and
parsing of the source code.
And also, on mobile devices,
you don't have to spend as
much CPU resources in loading
in the application, because
it's just a matter of
deserializing the heap.
All right.
KASPER LUND: It's important to
notice that this binary form
is completely
platform-independent.
It's the same thing you would
ship to a mobile device, that
you would ship to the desktop.
Even if it's like a 64-bit and
a 32-bit machine involved,
it's the same format.
So it's not about doing
a per-target
compilation of any sort.
This is just a binary form of
the source code, essentially.
LARS BAK: It doesn't contain
any generic code.
And it can handle going from a
32-bit machine to a 64-bit
machine, if you want
to do that.
All right.
Now.
Let's talk about the future.
One important part of this
project is to design a new
programming language.
And we are pretty much done
with that design process.
We have a form of specification
made.
You can download it and read it
if you want to, with a few
exceptions.
We have a few things
we will put in.
One is we will probably
eliminate interfaces, because
we also have abstract classes,
and they work
exactly the same way.
So these have just simplified
the language.
We'll also introduce mixins,
which allow you to do
co-sharing across inheritance
hierarchies.
That'll come in after
version one of Dart.
And then of course we'll have
some support for annotations,
because most IDEs say they
want annotations.
Java programmers want
annotations.
So that's how it is.
But anyway.
You should look at the
specification.
It's pretty much done, and
I hope you like it.
Otherwise send us comments.
So this is our timeline
we have on the
whiteboard in Denmark.
KASPER LUND: As you can tell,
up to 2009 we were busy
hacking on JavaScript,
making that faster.
And at some point Lars and I
decided to try to do something
a bit simpler than that.
We called that Spot, and
that was in 2010.
And we spent three months on
hacking up this new virtual
machine, a new programming
language, and
a new set of libraries.
And that was a lot of fun.
At some point it was so
promising that we decided to
turn it into a real project, and
it got re-branded to Dart.
And that's where we're at now.
So in 2011 we introduced Dart
as a technology preview, and
we've been getting a
lot of very good
feedback from that process.
So this here is all about making
Dart robust and really,
really fast.
And next year?
LARS BAK: Success.
KASPER LUND: That will do.
LARS BAK: So what we're working
on hard today is to
make sure that you have a
developer release in your
hands later this year, so you
can start relying on the
libraries, the performance
of Dart, and building
applications on top of it.
The release will include
the language--
fixed, hopefully, for
the first version--
libraries for the web and server
development, so you can
also write Dart applications
on the server side.
We have a programming
environment.
So some of it is based
on Eclipse.
And we also have a standalone
virtual machine, that's also
been integrated into
the Chromium build.
And that was the Dartium browser
you saw in the demo.
And then we have this translator
to JavaScript that
allows us to be compatible
with most browsers.
So this is exciting.
KASPER LUND: So in addition to
all that, Dart is already now,
and will remain, a fully open
source product here.
Dart is available under a very
permissive BSD license.
So if you want to take it,
run with it, use it for
something, have fun.
The entire idea is to try to
foster innovation in this
space, so it makes a lot of
sense for us to just put all
the bits and pieces out there,
and have a community based
around that.
It's developed in the open.
All our code reviews are on
public mailing lists, and all
the build bots are for
everybody to see.
It makes it much easier for us
to interact with members of
the community that have good
ideas or good feedback.
Already now we have a fairly
active community, and we're
getting a lot of very helpful
and very good feedback on new
ideas that we circulate
on the mailing list.
So if you're interested in
joining in, or at least trying
it out, you should go to some
of the online resources we
have available.
The primary site is
dartlang.org.
And there you'll find a lot of
information about how to
download the SDK and the
editor, and try it out.
So please try it out, continue
to give us good feedback.
LARS BAK: And one interesting
note is that since we released
it as a preview last fall,
we have had a few
changes to that platform.
There's now 9,000 revisions
since last fall.
So you can imagine that there's
a lot of change lists
coming out every day.
And we're really serious about
making this fast and
consistent.
KASPER LUND: It's fun to work
on a project like that, that
moves really quickly.
And it's fun to see people
that use it being excited
about the new changes, and
adapting their existing code
bases to new, interesting
things that
pop up in the language.
So it's been a fun process.
So there's even more about
Dart at this Google IO.
So this was a very sort of high
level presentation about
Dart, and the motivation
behind it.
If you're interested in more
details, I suggest you go to
the next talk, at 2:45 in Room
3, which is about building web
apps in Dart.
And you'll get more hands-on
experience with what it is to
build something new and
exciting in Dart.
There's also a talk about
migrating code that's written
in GWT to Dart in the
same room, Room 3.
And during the entire afternoon
here, from now,
essentially, to fairly late, we
have Dart office hours on
the Chrome demo floor.
So if you want to come chat with
us there, feel free to
drop by, and if you have
questions we'll be very happy
to try to answer them.
Tomorrow, if you're really
Darty, you should go to our
Bullseye, Your First Dart App
code lab, where you'll get a
chance to do some hands-on work
with the environment and
the product.
LARS BAK: And we are pretty
much at the end now.
So this is a summary slide.
I hope we managed to convince
you that Dart is a simple and
unsurprising object-oriented
language that
should be easy to use.
And it allows you to write
structured code, and also
develop tools that can analyze
these programs.
And it works on modern
browsers.
So we've had a lot of experience
in implementing
virtual machines for various
object-oriented languages.
This is the first time we are
doing a new language, and it's
a challenge.
But it's fun.
So thank you for listening.
And if you have any questions,
please line up in front of the
mics so we can capture
what you're asking.
KASPER LUND: Yeah, the final
thing here is to just make a
mental note of the fact that
it's fairly easy to build a
really high-performance, fast
virtual machine, at least
compared to building
a new language.
So we're having a lot of fun.
[APPLAUSE]
KASPER LUND: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hello?
KASPER LUND: Yes, it's on.
AUDIENCE: Is it the
same JavaScript--
it's cross-browser, or do you
have different versions for
different browsers?
KASPER LUND: So we generate
one version of
the JavaScript code.
And there are some parts
in there that are
browser-specific, but right
now we just compile one
version that deals with all the
differences in one file.
So one output, one JavaScript
file that works across all the
modern browsers.
AUDIENCE: One other question.
You've shown us the language,
but the APIs that you use to
access the DOM and the other
elements of the browser, are
those familiar?
LARS BAK: They are the same.
We're using the same DOM
interface as JavaScript,
except a few changes to make
it more consistent.
And we call it the Dart
HTML library.
So it's also available when
you download Dart.
If you go to the next talk about
Dart, you'll see how
that's being used for building
web applications.
But this talk was mostly about
the language, and not how to
hook it up to the web.
LARS BAK: If you drop by the
Chrome demo floor, I'm sure
someone can show you what
it is and how it
looks at the API level.
AUDIENCE: I had a question, I
guess more about the Dart
editor, but.
I've played with it a little
bit, and I was wondering if
there's plans to make an
official Eclipse plugin, so
that we can get all the version
control, and other
features of the Eclipse
platform.
LARS BAK: There's been a lot of
requests to get a plugin.
And behind the scenes it's
sort of the same.
So we will wrap it
up at some point.
I cannot give you a date when it
is there, but it will come.
KASPER LUND: Take one more here,
and then we'll switch to
that side for a while.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Sorry.
So what sort of integration,
or is there any integration
with Google Closure compiler
for JavaScript?
Like, do you guys pump out
minified, optimized
JavaScript?
Or is it just unminified and
then you pump it through
Closure afterwards?
KASPER LUND: So right now what
we're doing is we're
generating unminified but
optimized output.
And we're pushing hard on making
those optimizations
even better.
And we are working on
minification as well.
So we don't have any immediate
plans of using the Closure
compiler for doing this, because
sometimes we actually
use a lot of information, when
you go from our input to
JavaScript with type annotations
in common.
So we want to try to avoid
losing that kind of
information, and essentially
do the minification and
optimizations ourselves, based
on the fact that we understand
the Dart semantics even better
than the Closure compiler can.
LARS BAK: Minification is
actually very simple when you
have all the information
from the compiler.
So it's much easier to do it
ourselves than go through the
Closure compiler for
minification.
KASPER LUND: We also have a need
for minifying Dart code,
to make the download of
Dart code smaller.
So we will produce something
like a Dart-to-Dart
translator, that minifies
and optimizes.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
And just one other quick
question, is there any ability
to at runtime to load in
additional code, if you're
using binaries?
Or is it all done at
compile time only?
KASPER LUND: Actually we use
this concept that we actually
didn't introduce much here.
It's isolates.
And that's one way of creating
a completely new world that
you can populate with new,
dynamically loaded code.
And it's still a work in
progress, it's something that
we will be pushing more on.
LARS BAK: There's also
another way of
dynamically loading code.
We have a way of lazy loading
an entire library.
So when you say import to a
library, we'll say it should
be lazy loaded.
And you just have to activate
the loading.
And you cannot use the
[? interpoints ?]
that the library before it has
been completely loaded.
If you try to use it, it
throws an exception.
AUDIENCE: I just have
a question.
What is the recipe for
server [INAUDIBLE]?
So Dart is on the client side
sort of language, but how do
you envision the communication
between server and client
serialization?
[INAUDIBLE]
LARS BAK: So certainly
we support JSON.
So you can use the JSON format
to move stuff back and forth.
The language is not a client
language, it's
also a server language.
And we have a standard
loan VM you can run
on the server side.
And it has an I/O library
that supports--
[INAUDIBLE]
asynchronous way of doing I/O.
So you can write server code
in Dart, if you want to.
KASPER LUND: There's some work
going on with using something
like [? protobufs ?]
to communicate between
client and server.
There's a lot of community
interest in this area, too.
So it is very important to
stress that Dart runs just
fine on the server.
So you can write your code, the
client code and the server
code, in the same language, and
have that interoperate in
a nice way.
AUDIENCE: Does Dart support
compile time [INAUDIBLE], so
that I will be able to calculate
optimal parameters
before generating the code?
A good example of the use of
that is being articulated in
[INAUDIBLE]
and all the [INAUDIBLE]
programming language.
KASPER LUND: We have some
support for that.
It's not completely general, but
it's very simple, and it
works well.
That's in the form of what we
call compile time expressions.
There's a subset of the
language, essentially, that
you can use for building compile
time expressions.
And that includes user-defined
data structures, we call them
const objects, that are actually
built at compile time
rather than at runtime.
So there's some support
in the language there.
You should drop by the
demo floor, and I can
show you how it works.
LARS BAK: So for instance, in
the point example, if you make
the fields final, you
can make a const
constructor for the point.
So you make instances of point
as compile time expressions,
that are compiled
at compile time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: What did you mean
by success for 2013?
LARS BAK: That we still have
a job working on Dart.
No.
That was a joke.
Success means that in 2013 we
have a stable system that's
out in Chrome, and we have many
real projects outside
Google, also working on
Dart and using Dart
for deploying code.
This is the ultimate goal.
The premise here is to make sure
programmers will get a
much better platform for
writing applications.
And if you cannot demonstrate
that,
that's certainly a failure.
AUDIENCE: So do you expect
any [INAUDIBLE]
is going to [INAUDIBLE], since
it's already compatible over
most of of the JavaScript
stuff, that's OK?
LARS BAK: So your question is,
will the other browser vendors
take the Dart VM and integrate
it into their browsers?
Well, I cannot answer that,
since I'm not controlling what
they're doing.
But what I can do is, I can
make sure that Dart is an
appealing offer.
So it's out there,
it's open source.
And if we can demonstrate Dart
applications when running with
a native VM has instant
startup, and better
performance than a similar
JavaScript program, it seems
very appealing to me, if I was
sitting in the other camp and
then integrated.
And we hope that will
happen of course.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious if all of
the Dart language features
compile to JavaScript?
And I'm specifically curious
about covariant generics.
KASPER LUND: So, yeah.
So covariant generics are
reasonably easy to compile to
JavaScript.
There's nothing in JavaScript
that hinders that.
There's one area where it's
problematic to have the full
Dart language implemented when
translated to JavaScript, and
that's numerics.
JavaScript does not have any
efficient way of having
arbitrary sized integers,
for instance.
Everything is, when it comes
to numbers, a double in
JavaScript.
So there are some restrictions
on how numbers work in Dart
when compiled to JavaScript,
compared to what you get on
the native VM.
It's a hard problem to solve.
We're looking at ways
of doing that.
But for now that's the one
area where there's a real
difference between
the two setups.
LARS BAK: We have discussed
caving in, and just having
numbers like in JavaScript.
But boy, we really like
integers, and the
semantics of integers.
And mixing them all up,
I think, is a mistake.
So that's the reason why,
precisely in this area, that's
a little bit of discrepancy
between the native
implementation and the
JavaScript-generated code.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is Google going
to promote Dart over
GWT down the road?
LARS BAK: GWT already has a
lot of customers, and it's
still supported.
We think, since we have done the
Dart part and have nothing
to do with the GWT part, that
this is a better fit for the
web platform.
And during the presentation
we were talking about this
importance of immediacy when
doing programming.
The fact that you can change the
file and get it up running
right away, where there's no
tool chain in between you and
debugging the program--
this is something that's hard to
do in GWT, where it's much,
much easier to do in Dart.
At the same time, in Dart
you can avoid the types.
So if you prototype, you can do
crazy stuff and don't think
about the types, it'll
still work.
And I think that really will
help you accelerate your
prototyping of your
application.
AUDIENCE: Also I was just
curious about, for a project
of similar size, how does Dart
stack up against GWT in terms
of code generation,
[INAUDIBLE]
JavaScript code?
Is it smaller in size,
or larger in size?
LARS BAK: I don't have
comparable numbers right now.
What I can tell you is that the
generated JavaScript code
from Dart is fairly
minimal now.
You should try it out.
And we expected to be
much smaller than
what GWT can generate.
I think the GWT system is also
doing a lot of tree shaking
before they generate
JavaScript code.
But they have a lot of legacy
stuff related to the Java
libraries they're using.
But I don't have numbers
right now.
So go home and measure it.
Yes.
KASPER LUND: This will be the
last question, by the way.
AUDIENCE: Two questions.
So first, the syntax
for importing a
module is pound import.
Do you have some sort of
preprocessor that you can use,
with if defs and stuff?
KASPER LUND: No.
But it is true that right now,
the way to write an import is
using a pound import.
It is to try to make it stick
out, and it certainly does.
And we are thinking about making
it look more like an
integrated part of the
language, rather than
preprocessing.
But it was designed to make
it stick out, and it does.
AUDIENCE: Secondly, for
isolates, are they implemented
as threads?
Or is it somehow a thin--
KASPER LUND: Thread.
LARS BAK: Since we translate
to JavaScript and it has to
run on top of a single
JavaScript engine, we have to
multiplex between them.
But you can run isolates.
AUDIENCE: But in the
Dart VM itself?
LARS BAK: Yes, they're running
completely independent, so
that you can have isolates
running in parallel.
AUDIENCE: So they are
actual threads?
KASPER LUND: They don't have
to be [? native ?]
threads.
There is a thread pull
implementation that we're
working on, where essentially
you'll get as many threads
running as you need to--
as the amount of parallels
you have in your program.
So it's not tied to one thread,
and it's more like a
thin threading model.
LARS BAK: So for instance, if
the isolate is not active it
doesn't have to have a native
thread bound to it.
AUDIENCE: Does it have a
pre-allocated execution stack?
Fixed size stack?
KASPER LUND: No, so, everything
is asynchronous.
There's no blocking.
So you actually don't
need to do that.
You just have to return from
your isolate at that point.
It is an asynchronous model,
so there are no execution
stacks stuck on native
threads or anything.
So it's very simple that way.
LARS BAK: So we are using the
native execution stack when
executing an isolate.
KASPER LUND: Thanks
for staying for
the Q&A. We're done.
LARS BAK: Thank you.